hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sally sollte
gibt es eine matif torte für de la pena
ist schon ein jahr alt geworden
und ja das jahr verging superschnell was
eine schöne tore gemacht im innern habe
ich eine blaue bei torte natürlich denn
die kleider liebt tiere über alles
murat verteilt auch ab und zu noch ein
paar bleiben auf dem boden und als er
erst krabbeln konnte ist dann immer so
den halb morgen durch die wohnung
gelaufen er gekrabbelt und hat die blaue
bahn aufgefuttert und hier oben habe ich
eine schoko nuss nougat ortet auch
richtig lecker und vom design her habe
ich eine platte gemacht denn sie liebt
tiere über alles also wenn sie in
schafstädt machte und bei der kasse
machten und deswegen setzt auch sehr
gefreut also die tiere hier zum ersten
mal gesehen hat vom prinzip her
natürlich sehr aufwendig also ich habe
jetzt ein paar tage natürlich die
figuren modelliert dann die torte
gebacken aber chancen einfach aufgeteilt
auf drei bis vier tage
beim modellieren hat dieser mir ein
bisschen geholfen jetzt hier vorne dann
zum beispiel diese süßen kleinen enten
gemacht ganz ohne anleitung und ja ich
denke so im ganzen ist eine richtig
schöne kunterbunte torte geworden die
vor allem wahrscheinlich jedem kind
gefällt
ich habe das video so aufgeteilt dass
jetzt gleich zuerst einmal seht wie man
die figuren herstellen
denn die müssen zuerst einmal ein paar
tage natürlich durchtrocknen ihr könnt
die super vorbereiten schon zwei drei
wochen vorher und einfach irgendwo
lichtgeschützt lagern und trocknen
lassen und dann wird natürlich der boden
gebacken die cremes hergestellte torte
gefüllt und am ende alles zusammen
gesetzt also starten jetzt gleich mal
mit den figuren und ich gehe jetzt los
ich starte jetzt mit den tieren und ich
werde jetzt dafür modelle schokolade und
aber auch module von damit also von dort
mit blüten pasta bis interesse von land
und cnc bull vernehmen
und dazu gibt es auch schon ein video
jetzt ist erst mal die katze dran und
darf habe ich jetzt ein graues stück
modelle von land und das ist so groß wie
ein ei ungefähr und es wird jetzt einmal
durch geteilt
und aus der einen hälfte form ich jetzt
den kopf unter anderem den körper und
sortiere sehen immer ganz süß aus wenn
der kopf eben etwas größer ist als jetzt
in echt weil dann sehen sie einfach ein
bisschen baby haffter ausgangsform ist
jetzt eine kugel und den körper kann ich
jetzt auch bereits form und auch erst
eine kugel und dann so ein bisschen
spitz formen
beim kopf nehmt ihr euch jetzt ein ball
tool als ein ball werkzeug und da kommen
jetzt die augen rein
jetzt kommt da jeweils eine kleine weiße
kugel rein
die sitzt aus blüten passte und alle
teile die ich jetzt irgendwo irgendwie
festkleben klebe ich mit etwas essbarem
kleber an
jetzt freu' mich eine kleine braune
kugel und eine kleine schwarze kugel das
wird dann hier innen das auge und da
kommt doch noch ein kleiner weißer punkt
trennen
hier vorne an die schnauze kommen jetzt
zwei hellgraue kugel
und oben drüber eine kleine rosa nase
als nächstes die ohren dran und dafür
kommt hier oben in den kopf kommen zwei
löcher rein
und diese kleinen flachen ohren wir
werden jetzt hier vornherein geklebt und
dann nimmt die automodelle werkzeug als
hilfe den kopf gebe ich jetzt auch an
und stecken so ein bisschen fest damit
die figur schön zusammen bleibt und es
macht jetzt einfach in im zahnstocher
oder ihr nehmen zum beispiel ein paar
spaghettis
jetzt sind die füsse also die tatzen
dran und dafür nimmt er auch wieder eine
kugel formt sie zu einem großen tropfen
die drück dir leicht flach und schneidet
dann zweimal ein so dass die katzen
entstehen
jetzt sind die hinteren beine dran und
staffelt die die kugel und fand ein
bisschen länglich und das eine ende wird
jetzt ein bisschen flach gedrückt und
dann auch geformt
und unten werden dann wieder die tatzen
eingeschnitten
und für das schwänzchen da hinten kommt
jetzt ein spaghetti stück rein und das
wird jetzt darauf gesteckt
ich habe ich einfach die schnurrbart
haare dran geklebt und zwar ist es ein
bisschen blüten rating kann man
natürlich nicht essen und vor dem
verzehr muss man die auf jeden fall
entfernen
und jetzt kommt noch eine kleine
erholung in die ohren rein und das mache
ich jetzt auch mit ein bisschen modell
direkt zeigt
als nächstes ist die kuh dran und dafür
habe ich jetzt hier schon mal ein stück
weiter modelliermasse ein bisschen
tropfenförmig geformt da kommt ein
zahnstocher rein denn deco sitzt und
hier habe ich auch schon mal einen
kleinen kopf geformt und weise so ein
bisschen oval und flach gedrückt und da
kommt jetzt vorne die schnauze davor
mich jetzt ein langes hautfarbenes stück
und es wird jetzt ein bisschen flach
gedrückt
dann kommen da oben die nasenlöcher
rhein mit einer runden spritzte frau ist
nach den mund
der kopf drauf gesteckt jetzt sind die
ohren dran das habe ich jetzt schon zwei
kleine weiße kreise geformt und da kommt
jetzt ein bisschen hautfarbe wieder mit
rein
und bevor ich die wieder reinstecken
kommt ein kleines loch mit rein und dann
kommen die ohren an den kopf
und bevor die beine und die arme dran
kommen werde ich jetzt schon mal die
schwarzen flecken der gut drauf machen
und die mache ich jetzt mit ganz
normalen schwarzen sondern einfach immer
wieder kleine stückchen flach drücken
und angegeben
die arme und beine habe ich jetzt
ausweis stücken geformt einfach für
kleine längliche stücke die vorne etwas
dicker und hinten etwas dünner sind und
hier noch die hufen und zwar einfach
schon eine kleine kugel geformt aus
hautfarbe und habe den zip flach
gedrückt
jetzt muss ich die beiden teile
zusammenkleben und dann die hufe an
einer seite bisschen einschneiden
da kommen jetzt noch die schwarzen
punkte drauf also die flecken und an
beiden arme und beine auch angeklickt
die kuh ist fertig jetzt vor mich aus
pinkfarbenem modell schokolade noch die
zahl 1 und forme aus der pinkfarbene
modelle schokolade noch so eine kleine
schleife auf die zahl 1 klebe ich kleine
weiße punkte und lass die zahl dann
richtig gut aushärten bevor ich sie mit
zur kuhställe die schleife entsteht
durch zwei dreiecke die in der mitte mit
einer kugel verbunden werden
nun ist das schwein an der reihe
dafür verwende ich rosa modelle
schokolade
der körper wird wieder aus einem kegel
geformt und den kopf befestige ich mit
einem zahnstocher damit es schwein
sitzen kann die für beide sind ganz kurz
und kegelförmig geformt
die schnauze wir dann aus einem kleinen
runden stück angeklebt zwei nasenlöcher
stetig mit einem modell werkzeug ein und
für die augen verwende ich wieder die
vertiefungen und selbst eine weiße kugel
den mund öffentlich ganz vorsichtig mit
einer modelle werkzeug und setzte eine
rote zunge reihen
hinten muss dann nur noch das
ringelschwänzchen befestigt werden und
die augenbrauen werden dann mit einem
lebensmittelfarbstoff aufgemalt
als nächstes ist das schaf dran das
grundgerüst ist dafür wieder ein kleiner
kegel und diesen kegelte klebe ich mit
ganz vielen kleinen weißen kugel die
dann aussehen wie das kuschelige
schafspelz
der kopf des hautfarben und die nase
wird dieses mal nicht an geklebt sondern
eingeritzt der mund wird wieder ganz
vorsichtig mit einem modell ihr werkzeug
geöffnet und den kleide ich dann schwarz
aus und ganz süß sitz aus wenn man eine
zunge rein klebt die dann so ein
bisschen rausgestreckt wird
den kopf verkleide ich mit langen weißen
strengen und klebt dann noch die arme
und beine an
auf einer bauernhof forderte auf ein
stall natürlich nicht fehlen und diesem
modell ihre ich aus modelle schokolade
die dann gut aushärten kann mit hilfe
eines 10 jahres könnt ihr so das haus
die türen und die bretter ausschneiden
und für die holzoptik fritz ich dann
feinen linien ein
die blumen sind ganz einfach hergestellt
dafür braucht ihr nur fünf gleich große
kugeln die dann ganz förmlich aneinander
geklebt werden und für den richtigen 3d
effekt zeichne ich mit definierte kugel
dann noch eine linie 1 in die mitte
klebe ich dann noch eine gelbe kugel vor
sind die blumen dann fertig und die
können dann so ausdrücken für die
marienkäfer benötigt ihr eine rote und
eine schwarze kugel und die schwarze
kugel die soll minimal kleiner als die
rote seien die zwei werden dann
aneinander geklebt und die rote kugel
wird mittig eingeritzt so dass eben die
zwei flügel des marienkäfers entstehen
und für die fertigstellung klebe ich
dann noch die schwarzen punkte und die
augen an
der körper der biene ist oval geformt
und den lasse ich immer gerne kurz
antrocknen bevor ich dann die dünnen
schwarzen linien draufgelegt
die augen werden dann wieder aus einer
weißen und schwarzen kugel geformt und
hinten bekommt die biene dann noch einen
spitzen stacheln für die flügel nehme
ich eine kleine kugeln formen sie zu
einem tropfen und diese dann flach und
die einzelnen elemente also den stachel
und die flügel
die lasse ich vorher immer etwas an
trocknen bevor ich sie dann ankläger
für die kleinen fliegenpilze benötige
ich einen hautfarbenen fuß und einen
roten hut und den hut den förmig
kegelförmig mit einem modell werkzeug
und können dann ganz einfach auf den fuß
ankleben und die wayss gute dürfen
natürlich auch nicht fehlen
um realistische steine herzustellen
vertrete ich grau und weiß aber nur so
sehr dass die modelliermasse einfach
schön marmoriert bleibt daraus form ich
jetzt kleine und große unregelmäßige
steine
das könnte zum beispiel auch mit euren
kindern machen für die schnecke benötige
ich einen langen körper der vorne rund
und hinten spitz ist und der kopf wird
ganz leicht nach oben geklappt und die
dass ich einfach kurz stehen und
antrocknen das schneckenhaus sieht ganz
hübsch aus wenn man zwei oder sogar drei
farbig war und dafür verknetet man die
farben leicht miteinander und formt das
ganze dann zu einem strang und den
strang drehe ich dann wie eine schnecke
spiralförmig zusammen und klebt es
schneckenhaus vorsichtig an und die
augen und der mund wird dann wieder wie
gewohnt geformt
damit die tiere auf der torte richtig
kicken können benötigen sie natürlich
eine menge geburtstagstorte und auch so
ein bisschen obst und andere törtchen
und für die geburtstagstorte klebe ich
kleine farbige kreise übereinander und
befestige dann einen klecks sahne und
eine kirche aus modelliermasse drauf und
die kerze wird dann mit hilfe von
spaghetti angebracht oder mit draht
befestigt und das kuchenstück kann man
dann auch schön heraus schneiden und auf
einem teller setzen
und für die torte benötige ich dann noch
ein paar holzlatten die auch wirklich
sehr gut austrocknen müssen
die werden dann für den zaun benutzt und
die werden ganz realistisch wenn man sie
ein schneidet und dann feine linien um
löcher rein zeichnet ich habe jetzt alle
tiere fed modelliert und auch die ganz
kleinen in dekoration und hergestellt
und die last jetzt zwei bis drei tage
durch trocknen und einen tag vor last
geburtstag werde ich dann die torten
backen als tortenböden und die creme zu
bereiten und die torten auch gleich
füllen und mit ganache einstreichen und
auch mit fondant eindecken und am tag
vor dem geburtstag weil die torten
fertig dekorieren marken ist ehlers
geburtstagsfeier das heißt die figuren
sind jetzt schon ein paar tage durch
getrocknet und jetzt kann ich mich heute
um die torte kümmern
ich habe ein bisschen was vorbereitet
und freue mich jetzt die unsere torte
das wird eine heiße wette thron und
horte denn er liebt die heidelbeeren
also hab ich mir gedacht muss es auf
jeden fall ein halber torte werden für
den boden habe ich jetzt bereits einen
rührkuchen vorbereitet dass es ein rohr
öl teig mit gemahlenen mandeln und mit
etwas zitronenschale abrieb das aroma
dann habe ich hier eine französische
buttercreme dies gleich fertig stellen
werde
und die verfeinere ich mit heidelbeeren
und zwar deswegen weil ich französische
buttercreme wirklich sehr liebe man kann
sie vor allem unter fondant benutzen und
sie schmeckt sehr fruchtig man kann
wirklich total variieren auch mit
schokolade und deswegen hier die
variation mit heidelbeeren und ich habe
eine heidel bei frucht einlage gemacht
und alle videos findet ihr auch schon
als basic rezept bei mir auf youtube
kanal und natürlich auf dem blog jetzt
habe ich hier wie gesagt die
französische buttercreme und hab da die
eier wasser aufgeschlagen und wer jetzt
hier die butter noch kurz einrühren und
das ein gekochte heidelberg pury
einrühren
jetzt kommt noch dass heidel batterie
mit rein und für den geschmack noch ein
bisschen zitronenschale abrieb
jetzt werde ich die torte fühlen ich
habe jetzt hier ein kickboard als in der
kuchen platte was kommt ein bisschen
butter cremig drauf damit der teig so
ein bisschen daran haften kann und eine
strecke rutscht jetzt den untersten
boden den kuchen habe ich bereits in
drei teile geschnitten
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen buttercreme
drauf die verstreicht und da lege ich
jetzt die noch gefrorene frucht einlage
drauf gefreut deshalb weil man sie so
ein bisschen leichter transportieren
kann
und die sind immer etwas kleiner als die
torte damit sie einfach am rand nicht
herausschauen noch ein bisschen
buttercreme obendrauf
jetzt kommt der zweite tag drauf und
wird genauso geschichtet
und bevor die torte jetzt von außen
komplett mit der buttercreme glatt
gestrichen werden kann muss ich sie für
etwa eine halbe stunde bis stunde in den
kühlschrank stellen damit die
buttercreme fest wird dann wird sie
komplett mit der buttercreme
eingestrichen und kann dann mit fondant
überzogen werden
die overather wird eine 20 zentimeter
torte und zum ausgleichstor fruchtigen
torte gibt es da ein musiker schokolade
getourt ich habe einen ruhetag
vorbereitet denn rührteig mit
schokoladen speisen und gehackten hasel
wissen und habe eine vollmilch lukas
karlsch vorbereitet und eine bananen
birnen schokoladen einlage und im
prinzip wird diese torte genauso gefüllt
wie die untere
und auch diese torte muss jetzt gekühlt
werden bevor ich sie gleich mit der
restlichen ghana stand komplett platt
sprechen
ich hatte beide torten die glatt
gestrichen waren über nacht im
kühlschrank das heißt heute ist als
geburtstagsfeier die torten stelle kurz
zur seite
die untere wildes grün überzogen dafür
habe ich jetzt hier ein kilo grünen von
land bereits weiß geknetet und ist es
jetzt ein richtig schönes grünes
tannenbaum grün aber ich möchte ein
bisschen grasgrün deswegen kommt ein
bisschen geld betreiben und dann knete
ich den fordern jetzt noch mal gut durch
und rollen einfach auch ein bisschen
wecker stärke aus auch wecker stärke
gibt es einfach nicht und ich kann die
bäcker stärke vor allem wieder gut weg
an
jetzt wird auch die kleine torte mit von
dort überzogen und dafür habe ich jetzt
500 gramm weiß und ein kleines stück
blau dann müsste einfach drucken wie
intensiv ihre farbe haben möchtet dass
wir jetzt so einen schönen hellblau
verknetet und damit die karte gezogen
jetzt wird die torte zusammengesetzt ich
habe jetzt hier diese skateboard das ist
ein bisschen größer und ob es einfach
nur mal auf ein anderes stabile
skateboard gestellt und es wird sich
jetzt mit ein bisschen sondern da kommt
einfach ein bisschen kleber schulter und
den verteile ich jetzt mit einem pinsel
und da soll ich jetzt sind von land
rover aus
jetzt kenne ich die torte draufsetzen
und weil der von anti rhd noch ganz
frisch ist brauche ich da jetzt auch
keinen kleber dazwischen sondern kann
die torte gleich draufkleben uns damit
jetzt die obere torte die ziehung drauf
kommt die untere taten nichts dazu rückt
durch das hohe eigengewicht muss ich die
torte natürlich ein bisschen stützen
daher nehme ich jetzt solche gags und
zwar sind es ganz normale
kunststoffrohre die gibt es auch in
jedem baumarkt zum beispiel es gibt auch
rundhölzer oder ihr könnt cake pops
ticks nehmen aber die obere teil ist
wirklich sehr schwer deswegen greift
lieber auf diese kunststoffe zurück da
werde ich jetzt etwa drei bis vier stück
unten rein machen und die müssen dann
gleich auf die richtige höhe
zurechtgeschnitten werden lebensmittel
stift und kennzeichnungs und schneidet
sie dann so zurecht
ich habe jetzt unter zweiten torte keine
klebende schicht weil ich die tochter
einfach nicht transportieren muss wir
sind doch ein zuhause und die wtg dessen
falls ihr sie transportieren wollte auf
jeden fall und klinker oder eine creme
streifen damit die obere torte beim
transport nicht verrutscht ich werde die
ganze decke die ich vorbereitet habe auf
die torte kleben und einfach die torte
für den kurier
an
die tat ist jetzt fertig und ich kann
euch nicht sagen wie viele stunden ich
daran gearbeitet habe weil ich einfach
die arbeit immer auf mehrere tage
aufgeteilt haben
hier wollte ich euch noch kurz zeigen
sind die kleinen enten von sami rat
jetzt ganz ohne anleitung gemacht und
wir fahren es ist doch irgendwo ein
frosch dennoch meine schwester gemacht
das haben wir zusammen gemacht das war
richtig schön ja also die torte ist
wirklich super vor allem wenn sich die
ela bestimmt gleich freuen
gleich kommen meine gäste und dürfen sie
dann auch probieren deswegen kann es
jetzt natürlich noch nicht anschneiden
aber ich zeige euch einfach jetzt gleich
im anschluss ein paar bilder vor allem
für bilder von ella wie sie auch zu
toten reagiert hat schwimmer ist er
gespannt darauf sehr wahrscheinlich
große augen machen und falls ihr jetzt
diese torte oder so ähnlich oder in
abgespeckter version nach machen wollt
geht noch auf salihs - blog.de da stehen
noch einmal die genauen mengenangaben
und im prinzip könnt ihr sie erwägt sich
gestalten wie ihr wollt den geschmack
verändern wie er möchte und ich hoffe
natürlich dass er viel spaß beim
zuschauen hatte und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß
selbermachen bis zum nächsten mal